let's bring in our chief Washington
correspondent major Garrett major was
the Trump administration surprised by
the angry reaction from senators Mike
Lee and Rand Paul sure it was but it
left the response to one of their more
ardent defenders in the Senate Lindsey
Graham who said both senators were
embolden Amida prompted Rand Paul to
call that a gutter response that insults
the Constitution and uses a fake drape
of patriotism this kind of intramural
fighting among Republicans is clearly
going to fuel the debate later today on
the House floor about a War Powers
Resolution to limit president Trump's
further military actions in Iran and
with those two Republican senators
saying when that debate comes to the
Senate they'll side with Democrats the
White House has an unexpected problem on
its hands the president major falsely
claimed the Obama administration funded
Iran's missiles because of the Iran
nuclear deal what is the reality there
look if you really want to do a deep
dive on this go to the Washington Post
website Glenn Kessler the Washington
Post fact checker has a complete deep
dive on it but a few things this
ballistic missile was short-range
meaning it was old the Iran nuclear deal
provided funds that could have been used
for long-range ballistic missiles so not
the same technology the president uses
two figures from the Iran nuclear deal
both are exaggerated one wildly
exaggerated one slightly exaggerated
that's not my contention that's Trump
Treasury Department number contentions
in the main the accusation is
inflammatory it's reckless it's also
false major there's a big rally in Ohio
tonight that the president is holding
what do you expect the tone to be of
that considering all that is going on in
Washington and Iran that the president
will assert that this was a decisive
move that sulemani was a bad actor long
overdue
I participate the crowd will be
enthusiastic and it's general reaction
but the simple truth is this is
something that's being evaluated in a
political context there's no evidence
that the Pentagon the administration or
anyone around the president site that
this was a political maneuver for the
president this was a national security
step but you can't take the politics
away from it and everything that flows
from this decision will be viewed
politically if it worked
the president it will be an absolute
plus if bad things happen that haven't
happened so far he will own each and
every one of those consequences this
certainly does not appear or feel like
it's over thank you very much major
you